aujourd'hui d'un coup de griffe oui j'ai
un coup de richard ça va moins plaire au
marché bien sûr parce que moi je n'en
peux plus de l'arrogance du professeur
rawaj l'ado a lâché simon ibrahimovic a
mal au niveau des melons des jeux
l'adorent maiava moi je les adore on est
habité sur l'essai à répondre à une
interview de david pujadas que j'adore
là et ça a été encore une succession une
vague de tsunami de 2 de balayage de d2
tous les arguments qu'on pouvait lui
avancé alors je sais pas je trouve qu'il
ya pas de honte à un moment reconnaître
qu' on est un peu déçu par l'avancée des
essais par les résultats et qu'on s'est
peut-être trompé ya pas de honte à dire
ça même quand il est très brillant
il est connu mondialement pour ses
recherches il consacre sa vie ou malades
etc
y'a pas de honte à dire qu'à un moment
c'est peut-être un peu fourvoyé alors
que là il passé à fadiouth comme ça et
tout le charme échec un jeu sérieux va
le regarder regarder parce que qui dit
raul a fait énormément parler de lui
hier ils ont ça très bien marché 1 772
mille téléspectateurs pour l'interview
de didier raoult par david pujadas et il
a beaucoup fait parler lui parce qu'il a
sorti pas mal de punch line moi je vous
le dit voilà oui mais c'est un de mes
nouveaux héros je suis fan et d'en faire
la sonde aura bernard montiel qui est un
gros oui beaucoup de risque va me
raconter l'histoire c'est fou mais
regardez didier raoult qui a fait plein
de punch line moi je suis fan celle
ibrahimovic de la médecine ayant contenu
tant contraire je suis
extraordinairement élitiste je pense que
moi je suis partie de l'élite
contentieux pourrait très bien mais en
réalité ça change pas ma vie y voyez
écoutez moi faisait répondrai toujours
raison c'est moi terminer mais s'est
bien terminée alors deuxièmement laissez
votre avis deuxièmement je suis un
chercheur en fout un peu de ce qui se
pense aujourd'hui on joue pas dans la
même pièce de théâtre peut expliquer
pour nous ici on a traité 4000 personnes
je les ai vus c'est réel quand je suis
dans la vraie vie les tripes et vous les
gens qui pensent comme moi vous croyez
qu'ils pensent comme vous mais vous vous
trompez ils sont divisés
non non non aux coupes des troncs pour
vous les femmes un sondage entre vous et
moi on voulait faire un sondage entre
véran et moi pour voir qu'ils croient
voulais voir ce que c'est que la
crédibilité plus il a l'âge d'être mon
fils
franchement j'adore allons vous a fait
un top 3 des extraits qui ont fait
parler du professeur raoul à une guerre
ce que vous en pensez
l'adn extrait qui a fait le plus parler
c'est lorsque le professeur raoult est
revenu sur les institutions qui
déconseille la chloroquine et c'est
assez clair regardez ce qu'il y ait au
conseil à la santé publique bien de dire
ce n'est plus autorisé dans les hôpitaux
on formera votre traitement quelle est
votre réaction
si vous voulez combien plus de malades
ça me touche pas beaucoup affecté plus
j'ai derrière moi je voulais parce que
ça devait passer la désaveu
moi mon monde si vous voulez ne se
limite pas ni au périphérique parisien
ni même à l'hexagone
je suis désolé pour vous les au conseil
santé publique c'est le périphérique
parisien
non mais c'est une opinion commune
autres se saouler je m'en fiche un peu
alors logiquement lextreyt et trèbes
emblématique de toute l'interview il ne
répond jamais sur le fond il répond
toujours à côté et joue les élites
contre le peuple et joue à paris contre
la province et il joue à un concours qui
est le concours de miss france c'est lui
alors c'est mister france maintenant
dont ils demandent entre moi et veyran
jolie n'est pas besoin de ça je pense
sincèrement qui fait pas semblant je
pense que c'est comme les artistes il
doit être un scientifique les lumières
ne s'est pas placé m oui mais c'est un
grand santi c'est dire que c'est un
grand génie et en fait et c'est dans sa
nature d'être lunaire d'être comme ça
dit il crée d'être regardé vous le savez
beaucoup s'inquiètent d'une candidature
aux présidentielles du professeur à où
il a tenu à mettre fin aux rumeurs
regarder ne se présentera pas à regarder
je suis bien plus surpris
que vous de me retrouver en tête
d'affiche à ce niveau là à ce qui ce qui
me paraît pas raisonnable je l'apprécié
pas non honnêtement non à celle que
après tout le monde fantasme présenter
aux élections celui-ci les faire un
petit j'en aurais fait ses études à une
insulte et d'aires de penser que je
pourrais faire la politique parce que ça
veut dire que je fais pas bien mon
métier
voilà donc professeur willy fini avec
toutes les prouesses qui est fait pour
pour l'être humain est pour nous sauver
je pense qu'on le laisse faire ce qu'il
veut ils disent qu'ils ont manqué au
delà de ça il travaille pour le choc est
rude et il sauve des vies
tu vois c'est qu'au final on dépensé
beaucoup d'énergie et en avoir si la
chloroquine marché on n'aurait plus la
dépense et ce temps et cet argent va
travailler tout ce que m'a dit que toute
la france étaient rivés sur le problème
c'est tout le monde scientifique et
contre lille ça marche il a jamais dit
que c'est que la chloroquine son
traitement s'est couplée avec ce qu'on
fait mais les mecs l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
ce matin le oui messieurs matin à la
presse ce matin chez votre ami jean marc
morandini il y avait un infectiologue
formidable de la pitié salpêtrière si je
dis pas de bêtises qu'ils disaient
j'aurais adoré croire le professeur out
et d'ailleurs nous nous dans le temps
dans notre service
on a testé on a tenté on a tout fait ça
coûtait 5000 euros par patient on aurait
adoré que ça fonctionne or il est sur le
terrain le type est dit ça ne
fonctionnait pas alors donc croire c'est
pas forcément l'amour fou entre le
professeur raoul ministre de la santé
olivier veron et david pujadas a cherché
à faire réagir le professeur a ou sur
les tacles de veron à l'encontre du
didier raoult regardez vous avez quand
même répondu quand vous aviez dit
l'épidémie s'est terminée didier tu es
un bon médecin à bon chercheur un
excellent virologues reconnu mais un tu
n'en sais rien 2 tu t'es planté la
première fois quand tu pensais qu'il n'y
aurait pas de premières vagues
donc voilà olivier derand il vous avez
jeu
je ne commente pas non plus jamais ce
que disent les gens je le déplore parce
que je veux pas être désagréable plus il
a l'âge d'être mon fils donc j'ai
beaucoup d'indulgence pour lui si vous
voulez détrompez vous les gens qui
pensent comme moi vous croyez qu'ils
pensent comme vous mais vous vous
trompez ils sont divisés
non non non aux coupes des trompes on
voulait faire un sondage entre véran et
moi pour voir qu'ils croient ou les voir
ce que c'était
je savais que médiatiquement parlant ça
fait plaisir de voir un docteur qui sera
perdue qui sort du moule qui bouscule
les codes et d'ailleurs c'est le député
bus et pujadas qui s'est déplacée et non
pas le contraire il s'est déplacé à
marseille et phonique sur la question de
la présidentielle c'est pas elle pas si
étonnant cette question j'ai regardé sur
les réseaux il a une communauté malades
c'est incroyable ce qu'il adorait cinq
dix mille personnes sur facebook sur des
groupes à part entière surtout un peu
partout dans l'appartement voir que dans
la france maintenant on va regarder
regarder le sondage sur le professeur
awa tu as tu pris la grosse tête oui à
52% d'art à 48 5 à 2 avec ce montage
c'est normal moi je suis fan ans
véronique l'algérie je pense pas qu'ils
apprennent à goumois non plus qu'il est
dans son truc et dans son mode et voilà
il a essayé vous le savez on fait ça me
fout les génies la veillée on critique
toujours les gérer avec les regarder
eric vous aider dans son monde
il est dans le monde de la médecine ici
tu pense pas comme moi tu es mauvais
c'est parce qu'il est juste parce que je
prends ce qu'il se fait remarquer qu'il
a fait avec la chloroquine au début je
prends ce qu'il a dit au mois de mars il
a dit n'y aura pas de deuxième vague au
mois de mai ça sera fini on a au mois de
mai et je croise les doigts pour que ce
soit fini et je me pose des questions
la chloroquine je connais des gens qui
ont été soignés avec la chloroquine or
peut-être qu'ils auraient été guéris
même santé s'inquiète je me pose alors
une deuxième question si c'est un
guignol
pourquoi l'armée française a commandé
pour 100 kilos de la tyrannie bon les
militaires allemands de services à
guignol ah bah non mais quand tu entends
parler
moi je moi j'en ai marre aussi de voir
des gens qui skie qui consultent plus
qu'ils voient plus de médecins qui
voient plus de patients qui n'ont jamais
pris un set au scope dans les mains
depuis je sais pas combien d'années et
qui vient de dire que raoult c'est un
guignol
en attendant lui il est à l'hopital
congelés bardot qui voit des gens ils
voient des genres il est pas le cas des
médecins qui viennent sur les plateaux
qui consultent plus rien ça fait des
années mais ils viennent critiquer round
roxy mollahs qui conçut vrai mais c'est
le prix de la chloroquine moi je me dis
c'est bizarre je ne veux pas entendre
après on a trouvé un traitement mais ces
cinquante fois cent fois plus cher que
la chloroquine l'impression que ça
dérange 1
le prix de ce médicament qui est en
vente depuis 1940 et maintenant il est
dangereux il a tué des gens mais depuis
1940 il avait tué personne geder j'ai
une copine une copine qui est soigné à
la chloroquine depuis depuis des années
parce qu'elle a fait d allergie au
soleil et ou machin mais elle à magra
marmoutier non mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai on parle d'un truc en argot
route on parle d'un truc moi j'aurais
voulu savoir je laisse j'aurais voulu
savoir combien internet
combien c'est parce que moi je suis très
content j'aurais voulu savoir combien de
personnes qui étaient traités à la
chloroquine toute l'année combien ont
attrapé le covin argent va le savoir un
mot mais je suis très pc le scientifique
qui bat c'est en effet le livre c'est
pas le livreur là c'est le cas on peut
pas les moyens n'a pas de chiffres